[Musique]
on va être clair le virus aujourd'hui il
est là juste pour le fric la
désinformation basé sur la copie 19 ne
prend pas de répit à preuve cette vidéo
virale qui circule abondamment et qui
prétend qu'il existe un brevet depuis
2004 pour le corps en à virus à
l'origine de la coved 19
n'oubliez pas que le virus soit 10 ans
inconnue il ya quelques temps nous on a
retrouvé des papiers de 2003 ce serait
la preuve selon cette vidéo que le virus
a été créé inventé en laboratoire méfiez
vous de cette publication et les fausses
et en plus elle se répand à la vitesse
grand v
elle a été relayée à des centaines de
milliers de reprises vu à des millions
de reprises on voit donc un homme
prétendent que l'heure est grave et
brandir ce brevet qui d'ailleurs est
accessible sur le web vous pouvez le
consulter vous même le brevet existe
donc depuis 2004 pour un vaccin contre
le strass le strass c'est une autre
maladie de la même famille de virus
la famille des coronavirus c'est un
brevet de l'institut pasteur un
organisme à but non lucratif qui entre
autres développe des vaccins
en gros ce brevet ne fait que décrire la
découverte du virus en question et
surtout décrire l'invention de ce qu'on
appelle une stratégie vaccinale contre
ce virus
donc rien à voir avec l'invention d'un
virus celui du corona virus à l'origine
de la coved 19 pour plus de détails sur
cet autre exemple de désinformation basé
sur la coved 19 à les lire l'article de
mon collègue des finances sur la page
web des décrypteurs radio canada.ca
barres obliques décrypteurs au pluriel
et si vous voyez passer sur le web
d'autres publications qui vous semble
louche trompeuses ou carrément fausses
écrivez nous à la boîte courriel des
décrypteurs décrypteurs au pluriel un
commercial radio tirait canada place
[Musique]